medio de aplausos finalmente aterriza
[Aplausos]
las 5 meses de vuelo sara ruth de fort
se convirtió en la mujer piloto más
joven en volar en solitario alrededor
del mundo jam el asfalto la británico
belga se esfuerza por recuperar la
compostura es una verdadera locura creo
que todavía no me entra en la cabeza me
refiero al llegar aquí he llorado mucho
imaginando cómo sería estar por fin en
casa después de cinco meses e incluso
este último vuelo no es lo fácil así que
estoy súper contenta de la joven
prodigio surco a los cielos a los 14
años salió de bélgica en agosto y desde
entonces ha sobrevolado los ardientes
bosques californianos las estepas
siberianas y el desierto de arabia
saudita
su gira mundial debía durar menos de
tres meses pero se prolongó por
problemas de visado y por el mal tiempo
porque con este avión ultraligero de
hélice es imposible volar con nubes o de
noche
y
lo más difícil fue sin duda sobrevolar
siberia ya que hacía mucho frío - 35
grados en el suelo y si el motor se
paraba la ayuda tardaría horas en llegar
y no sé cuánto tiempo puedo sobrevivir
al menos 35 grados sobre rechaces
pronto sara rutherford emprenderá nuevas
aventuras entrando a la universidad para
estudiar ingeniería la joven sueña con
volar algún día más alto y convertirse
en astronauta